alors que la grève dans les raffineries
mais de plus en plus à mal le
gouvernement moi je souhaite vraiment
que ce mouvement de grève s'arrête le
mouvement s'apprête assez largir et
pourrait bien semer la pagaille demain
dans l'Hexagone le 18 octobre il y a à
peine la grève générale les gens en
immortel pas des salariés de
lagroalimentaire de l'éducation de la
santé de l'énergie du commerce ou encore
des transports compte à leur tour suivre
la grève ils demandent l'augmentation
des salaires mais défendent aussi le
droit de grève alors que la semaine a
été marquée par des réquisitions dans
des raffineries
routier SNCF raffinerie allons-nous
assister à un mardi noir demain par tout
en France
[Musique]
alors demain que va-t-il se passer merci
Fabien Villedieu délégué syndical sur le
rail merci d'être avec nous vous allez
nous dire ce qui va se passer demain et
merci Yacine Giwa CGT RATP bus merci à
tous les deux d'être là merci beaucoup
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a envie de
savoir ce qui va se passer demain
aujourd'hui
on en est où alors est-ce qu'il va se
passer des choses demain ou pas du tout
allez-y Fabien déjà ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que demain c'est pas
une grève de la RATP de la SNCF c'est ça
demain c'est une grève générale voilà un
petit concerne tout le monde et qui
concerne le pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui
on a un moment donné un peu stratégique
c'est que on voit qu'il y a l'inflaction
qui augmente et face à cette inflation
qu'est-ce qu'on fait soit on fait comme
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement jusqu'à
présent en disant s'il vous plaît les
patrons qui ont la possibilité augmenter
le salaire de vos salariés et on voit le
résultat le résultat fait que les
augmentations lorsqu'elles existent
elles sont en dessous de l'inflation
donc faut bien comprendre ça une
augmentation sous l'inflation
c'est-à-dire vous perdez du poids
d'achat soit on essaye une autre méthode
et l'autre méthode c'est quoi ça a été
la méthode des raffineurs les raffineurs
ils ont fait quoi ils sont mis en grève
vous soutenez les raffineurs évidemment
je soutiens la raffiné enfin je pense
que c'est un problème de pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est le
problème dont on avait parlé il y a très
longtemps
on l'a dit il faut que le gouvernement
aide les entreprises voilà pour qu'il
puisse voilà par votre employé des gens
pour que les entreprises soit moins à la
gorge qui est énormément de charges mais
derrière et c'est là où c'est vrai qu'il
faut que derrière avec moins de charges
si les l'état aide les entreprises ils
augmentent les salariés à un niveau
correct c'est un niveau au niveau de
l'inflation au moins un minima et c'est
vrai que là il y a eu énormément d'aide
pour les entreprises je le dis alors il
y a des entreprises qui ont été eu des
grosses difficultés avec le covid etc
mais il faut le dire l'état a mis en
place beaucoup beaucoup de choses pour
sauver les entreprises il y a des
entreprises des multi des
multinationales qui ont fait même des
qui qui sont très très bien sur qui ont
fait d'énormes bénéfices grâce aux aides
de l'État mais derrière c'est vrai que
ça n'a pas suivi chez les salariés en
fait là aujourd'hui je pense que le
problème ce qui se passe non les
différents corps de métiers là on la vie
avec les raffineries on le voit avec
vous on va le voir avec la RATP c'est ça
c'est que il y a eu énormément d'aide
mais les gens et les salariés attendent
que eux aussi soient aidés il y a eu qui
soit à minima au niveau de l'inflation
et ça on tout à fait donc demain vous et
vous vous serez en grève moi je suis en
grève dès ce soir après demain il y aura
des assemblées générales
à la SNCF et on posera la question de la
grève reconductible parce qu'on a fait
plusieurs journées de 24 heures on a
fait une journée de 24 heures le 6
juillet on a fait une journée de 24
heures le 29 septembre qui est
d'ailleurs pas trop passé dans les
médias voilà on a au niveau interpro et
à un moment donné quand vous on a cranté
on a décidé de cranter donc on m'a
proposé aux cheminots mais pas qu'au
cheminots parce que les problèmes de
salaire ça concerne tout le monde et je
franchement je dis aux gens ne vous
faites pas avoir aujourd'hui on passe
notre temps à opposer les gens qui sont
dans leur voiture avec les refiner là
cette semaine on va vous poser avec les
employés
l'histoire de l'augmentation des
salaires ça concerne tout le monde donc
il faut être demain aux manifestations
moi je pense qu'au-delà des
manifestations je sais pas après il faut
et ce que je vous attendez je pense tous
les gens que je vois passer sur sur ce
plateau ils attendent juste un dialogue
aussi ils attendent qu'on qu'on leur
explique les choses et qu'on leur dise
voilà qu'elle va être le plomb si tu
n'as aucune perspective un moment et ben
tu te dis ben moi je tourne en rond j'ai
besoin de savoir ce qui va se passer
j'ai besoin de savoir si je vais être
augmenté j'ai besoin de savoir voilà
aujourd'hui on voit la vie qui augmente
voilà et que c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
c'est devenu ça devient n'importe quoi
et à un moment tu te dis quand moi je me
lève je vous le dis à 8h du matin je
rentre à 18h et que le soir je me
demande ce que je vais bouffer et que et
si je vais pouvoir bouffer le 15 du mois
à un moment tu dis il y a un problème
moi je vois toujours appris si tu
travailles tu peux vivre aujourd'hui si
tu travailles mais tu es quand même dans
la merde donc à un moment c'est vrai que
je peux comprendre ça aussi après
vous aussi vous êtes mine de rien vous
devez être dans votre vie de tous les
jours pénalisé parce qu'il se passe dans
les raffiner aujourd'hui mais ça vous
empêche pas aussi de les soutenir c'est
ça Yacine ouais bien sûr de toute façon
il y a même un sondage qui a été fait
par Le Figaro et d'autres médias qui est
pas je veux dire une ligne éditoriale
très très gênée ils sont plutôt juste le
Figaro voilà et on l'a vu que voilà les
les personnes sont des ont répondu
majoritairement qui soutenaient les
raffineurs alors que voilà tout le monde
enfin nous à la RATP quand on commence à
4 heures du matin on n'a pas d'autre
choix que de ce que vous gagnez à peu
près 16007 après ça dépend des primes
quelqu'un qui va faire d'une auxiliaire
va gagner et vous travaillez qu'on adore
par jour là on est à peu près à cette
cette heure 34 par jour d'accord donc
vous travaillez tous travailler du lundi
au vendredi bah c'est des horaires
décalés il y a besoin de transport tous
les jours
et 1600 et 700 euros voilà et c'est la
pénurie tous ceux qui prennent les
transports en commun on voit qu'il est
temps d'attente pour les bus ont
augmenté voilà comme je dis à des
collègues Thanos n'a pas claqué des
toits pour faire disparaître les
conducteurs de bus ils ont des missionné
ils ont quitté leur poste parce qu'ils
n'en pouvaient plus ils voyaient que
tout augmente leur facture d'électricité
ça devient de plus en plus compliqué à
chaque fois on demande de serrer un peu
plus comme ça un moment l'entreprise qui
fait des bénéfices comment tu fais là on
peut pas comment tu fais quand tu te
lèves pour aller bosser tu te retrouves
avec des horaires aussi le week-end et
que tu dis même tes enfants moi je vois
il y a des gars ils disent moi mes
enfants je rentre le soir ils me disent
papa j'ai envie de faire ça j'ai envie
d'aller même une fois par mois aller au
restaurant je peux pas il va partir le
matin il me voit rentrer le soir je sais
pas quelle heure ils me disent alors
qu'est-ce que tu fous de la journée
c'est pas possible non mais c'est vrai
c'est c'est devenu et je peux comprendre
à 1600 1700 euros rendez-vous compte
alors et je le dis au téléspectateurs
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui qui crient qui gueule qui se disent
c'est son épinalisé et il y a beaucoup
de gens qui s'appénalise les infirmières
les pompiers les médecins les la police
etc mais il y en a beaucoup aussi qui se
disent un moment on peut comprendre
aussi voilà moi je vous entends voilà
moi j'entends tout à fait à 1600 1700
euros quand vous travaillez voilà 7h30 à
8h par jour c'est voilà c'est ça
exactement et c'est déjà au-dessus c'est
dans le média donc ça imaginez
là combien j'ai de messages de personnes
qui me disent on plus rien faire on est
on ne vit plus aujourd'hui on survit on
aimerait bien juste vivre voilà c'est
tout donc demain vous aussi vous allez
faire oui demain et aussi après-demain
et j'espère que d'autres secteurs vont
se mobiliser parce que la question des
salaires elle est elle touche pas que
les travailleurs à la SNCF à la RATP
mais elle touche l'ensemble des
travailleurs et je pense qu'à un moment
on parlait de l'inflation il faut
vraiment qui est scindé c'est à dire que
ce soit exactement
nulle part en Belgique et juste à côté
c'est ce qu'ils ont voilà on a vu on a
vu que les raffineurs de se battre 10%
d'augmentation voilà vous vous demandez
juste au niveau animal l'inflation à
chaque fois c'est à dire que on se cale
sur l'inflation exactement
après je peux être on va dire que je
suis démago moi je comprends franchement
c'est c'est tout à fait logique je
comprends c'est vraiment perd de pouvoir
d'achat bah oui donc c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui d'ailleurs existait jusqu'en 83
l'indexation sur l'inflation ce qui
existe au niveau du SMIC parce que les
gens se sont pas toujours au courant
mais le SMIC
et notamment elle RATP il y a on les
assure pas les plans de transport il
manque de chauffeur c'est la même chose
à SNCF moi ça fait 22 ans que je suis à
la SNCF sur ma ligne d où je suis
conducteur à partir du mois de de les 15
jours de tout ça le plan de transforme
va baisser pourquoi parce qu'il manque
de conducteur c'est-à-dire que on a fait
passer un centre d'entreprise faut se
dire les choses comme la RATP comme la
SNCF comme un peu la planque voilà et on
nous a tapé dessus et on a fait un
certain nombre de réformes qui fait
qu'on nous a tellement tapé dessus
qu'aujourd'hui des boîtes publics qui
assurent un service public n'arrive plus
à recruter moi ça me rend dingue ça me
rend dingue qu'une boîte comme la SNCF
qui fait du service public n'est plus
attractive n'arrive plus à assurer ses
plans de transport et obliger de
supprimer des trains parce qu'on va nous
parler des trains qui seront supprimés
demain mais en fait c'est tous les jours
qu'il y a des trains supprimés pourquoi
parce qu'elle n'arrive pas à embaucher
des agents commerciaux des agents du
matériel des conducteurs parce qu'elle
est pas assez attractive donc si on
augmente les salaires et ben on rend
l'entreprise attractive et du coup on a
moins de galère tous les jours alors
pour faire un point le syndicat
majoritaire dans accompagnement
secondaire aussi annoncé se joindre à la
grève de mardi cette grève est également
soutenue par le syndicat SUD éducation
voilà je vous le dis au niveau santé la
CFDT santé sociaux appelé les salariés
de la santé à rejoindre la mobilisation
pour expliquer leur mécontentement faire
la face à la stagnation des salaires
aussi dans le monde de la santé énergie
on l'a dit les raffineries sont déjà
l'arrêt depuis quelques jours et cette
crise pour encore s'intensifier ensuite
voilà je vous le dis c'est c'est
vraiment une grève générale demain dans
les transports les transports publics
comme vous l'ont dit comme vous l'avez
dit ils sont très perturbés demain les
cheminots de la SNCF comme les salariés
de la RATP sont appelés à cessé le
travail ce mardi 18 octobre Eurostar a
déjà indiqué que certains trains vont
être annulés et voilà et on annonce du
côté de la SNCF 4 1 sur 2 étant est
attendu en région demain donc c'est vrai
que voilà c'est une graine massive après
je pense que qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit
est-ce que vous sentez que vous allez
être entendu
écoutez en tout cas on va on va essayer
voilà moi je il y a une chose que je me
suis toujours dit c'est que je supporte
pas quand on gueule devant son café en
disant ah franchement donc pas mon
salaire et bien à un moment donné on a
la possibilité de se bouger là on peut
se bouger certains peuvent se mettre en
grève certains ne peuvent pas certains
ton cas beaucoup peuvent venir à la
manif à 14h place d'Italie on peut
chacun mettre sa petite pierre à
l'édifice et très honnêtement si on se
bouge pas sur la question des salaires
ce qu'il faut se rendre compte c'est que
l'inflation qu'on a en 2022 c'est rien
par rapport à ce qui nous attend 2023
donc tous les jours on va pleurer que
lorsqu'on fera les courses enfin moi
c'est dingue dès que je fais des courses
j'en ai au moins pour 100 balles tu
remplis pas ton clavier tu en as pour
100 balles tu vas aujourd'hui combien
moi j'ai pas une grosse voiture
dès que tu fais ton plein tu en as pour
100 balles mais c'est un truc de dingue
aujourd'hui vous sentez quand vous
achetez la même chose voilà vous faites
le même caddie on vous en avez quoi pour
30% de plus mais c'est l'augmentation et
aujourd'hui on se rend compte par
exemple qu'aujourd'hui on se bat pour
des augmentations de deux trois pour
cent
qui augmente de 2-3% rien l'essence à
elle prend 20% là j'ai vu les produits
alimentaires ils ont pris 10% tout
augmente de à deux chiffres et nous on
est là ah on se bat pour deux trois
pourcents rappelez-vous les raffineurs
ils étaient là pour 10% la boîte à leur
proposer 7 il y avait un delta de 3 % et
il voulait pas laisser passer ça alors
qu'en fait finalement les augmentations
dans la vraie vie mais c'est en double
c'est du 10 20 ou 15 %
alors il y en a un qui ce weekend c'est
Benjamin Castaldi voilà on vient d'en
parler la situation est très compliquée
il faut attendre un mardi noir et
Benjamin il a bonne idée de pousser
cette story je sais pas si vous étiez
bourré
vos visiblement ma suggestion à CGT
Confédération n'est pas suffisante voici
donc une nouvelle idée pour totale
énergie vous proposer 7% d'augmentation
une prime de 3000 à 6000 euros avec une
pipe un mars et un bounty pour le goût
du Paradis donc c'était pour pour
l'énergie uniquement pour la branche
pétrochimie d'accord oui évidemment que
les infirmières sont mal payées vraiment
que
ils ont payé sur 14 mois il y a une
proposition 7%, c'est pas rien même si
c'est ça je crois qu'ils veulent
si j'étais refusé 7% de la prime sur 14
mois ici oui on parle souvent de ceux
qui sont vraiment dans les maires de 15
du mois et je suis désolé dans ce
secteur là quand on parle de 2300 2100
2800 € par mois et qui a des primes en
plus je suis désolé alors ça voilà à mon
avis il faut arrêter de faire chier le
monde parce que ils sont beaucoup mieux
lotis que beaucoup de gens et il y a
plein de gens qui ont font en métier
normaux normal pardon qui peut pas se
mettre en grève parce qu'effectivement
leur patron les fous dehors moi j'ai un
métier que j'y vais à Nouna fais-moi 10
% de plus sinon je me casse et vous
allez me dire bah casse-toi oui je vous
dirai ça et ben voilà mais voilà
5% non mais bon au bout d'un moment il
faut voilà il faut il faut comprendre
les choses il faut essayer de balader de
faire un effort et de faire vous voulez
souvent c'est pas blond ou noir et dans
dans leur cas à eux dans le cas alors
SNCF c'est vrai ça fait des années qu'il
y a des grèves et vous battez pour la ce
qui est normal mais dans leur cas dans
cette branche la P3 quand il est moyenne
a dit qu'on allait gagner voilà non mais
c'est pas on va pas
qui s'augmente de plus de 50
%, c'est bien sûr ça vous a floqué moi
c'est ça qui me choque c'est pas c'est
une augmentation et quand on sait ce qui
respire c'est à dire que je voudrais
voir les études il respire des des des
produits toxiques c'est ça la longueur
de journée j'aimerais bien connaître le
espérance de vie à la fin 7 mois voilà
donc ça c'est important
la qualité et ça se paye tout ça je suis
d'accord non mais c'est vrai
ça marche pas ça il a bien cette envie
bien sûr ça c'est un chiffre on n'est
pas assez vous rendez compte ou pas non
mais je comprends que les mecs aussi bah
oui il y a un moment ça c'est il faut
sur payer je suis d'accord moi je trouve
qu'on est beaucoup trop dur avec les
grévises
tous les métiers sont à des pollution
bien sûr
beaucoup trop dur avec les grévisses y
compris dans les raffineries déjà on
connaît pas les coulisses de leur métier
comme on l'a dit et puis le message
qu'on envoie c'est tes salariés tu
prends ce qu'on donne et tais-toi mais
je suis désolé ça marche pas comme ça
moi ça me choque une entreprise qui
fasse des dizaines de milliards de
bénéfices n'augmente pas de 10 %, c'est
salarié et le succès d'une entreprise
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit la
dernière fois ok c'est un patron mais
c'est aussi des salariés qui bossent
pour une entreprise il faut les
respecter quand vous faites des dizaines
de milliards de bénéfices c'est honteux
de pas augmenter les salariés quand on
sait que l'inflation elle est
effectivement dans la vraie vie à 10 %,
20 % 30 % et que pour 2%, il négocie etc
moi je trouve ça honteux je suis désolé
on est trop dur avec les grévistes